good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack Van
Horn from the University of Virginia and I
am very proud to welcome you to this edition
of our 2022-2023 foundations of biomedical
data science seminar series the lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated translational Health
Institute of Virginia the UVA brain Institute the
College of Arts and Sciences the school of data
science and through a grants from the National
Institutes of General Medical Sciences since
2016 the foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series is focused on the use of data
science methodology's artificial intelligence
deep learning and statistical modeling as they
pertain to differing themes in the biomedical
and Health Sciences this year's theme is data
science and the public health consequences of the
covid-19 pandemic where each Friday we listen to
talks from leading thinkers about the issues
promises opportunities and hurdles associated
with understanding the secondary health effects
of covet 19. these include delayed Health checkups
and treatments and mental health and drug abuse
increased obesity and the long lingering health
effects associated with this terrible virus
indeed our 2022-2023 application cycle is now
open and will be for only a few more days and so
time is running out we really encourage you to if
you're a junior faculty member working in this
space or working in spaces such as infectious
diseases epidemiology clinical medicine population
Health as well as data science machine learning
Ai and statistics and other relevant domains to
please consider applying we have doing this for a
while now and we believe this is a very exciting
and engaging program where characterizing the
secondary health effects this year characterizing
the secondary health effects of covid-19 really
necessitates unique quantitative approaches
but also new multi-disciplinary collaborations
the participants selected for our biomedical
data science Innovation lab program will
leverage presentations like we're about to hear
as vital material for our culminating in-person
Grant project development Workshop to be held at
the lodge at St Edwards Park in Seattle Washington
in June of 2023. so today I am delighted to
welcome our speaker Dr vinay pai from the U.S
Food and Drug Administration Dr pai is one of
our mentors this year for our biomedical data
science Innovation lab and he is a digital health
specialist within the digital Health Center of
Excellence at the Food and Drug Administration
Center for devices in radiological Health in the
office of strategic Partnerships and Technology
Innovation part of the division of Health at the
FDA and he's been there since uh September
of 2019. uh vinay has his PhD in mechanical
engineering from Florida State University and
earned a masters of Business Administration
from John Johns Hopkins University currently he is
focused on Horizon scanning for new digital Health
Technologies evaluating existing and emerging
digital Health Technologies and helping to develop
strategies for how to evaluate them prior to his
time at the Food and Drug Administration Renee
was at the National Institutes of Health First as
a staff scientist in the National heart lung and
Blood Institute and then as a program of officer
and division director for biomedical Imaging
informatics and health informatics at the National
Institute of biomedical Imaging and bioengineering
before the NIH vinay was a faculty member at New
York University School of Medicine developing
techniques using proton and hyperpolarized
helium magnetic resonance imaging to study
cardiac and lung function in continuing with our
2022-2023 biomedical data science seminar series
the nay's lecture today is entitled so you want
to Market your regulated digital Health device
in the United States as fda's Center for devices
in radiological Health recently established the
digital Health Center of Excellence to provide
regulatory advice guidance and support to the
fda's regulatory review of device software
functions a large number of early stage digital
Health Products struggled to get to the U.S market
due to the perception of difficulty navigating
the cdrh regulatory processes vinay is going to
walk us through the various Pathways for bringing
digital Health devices and Technologies to Market
in the United States he's also going to highlight
the guidance documents within the digital health
and medical device portfolios which can help and
be useful during the process of moving digital
Health Technologies from prototype to real world
deployment as always we are streaming this
lecture live and for recording via YouTube
and if you are watching on YouTube thank you so
much for joining us also our specially selected
2022-2023 biomedical data science Innovation
lab participants and alumni are encouraged to
submit any questions they have for Dr pai via
the chat feature in their Zoom sessions I will
synthesize these questions and ask them on your
behalf during the last 10 minutes or so of the
lecture and with that vinay welcome we are so
excited to have you here speaking to us today
so excited to have you as a mentor and we are
really looking forward to hearing your lecture
thanks Jack uh hope you can hear me well
um and you can see my slide yep thank you
um thanks again for the introduction and I'm going
to jump right into the presentation because it's
fairly extensive um and my presentation is
going to focus uh the way I'm planning on
doing this by showing some background content
on the agency and the technology that we're
working with before doing a deeper dive into
guidances that are applicable for digital health
um when you talk about the U.S foreign Drug
Administration it's a it's a regulatory agency
and the key word that is Regulatory and our
responsibility is protecting Public Health
um the agency does this through regulating
a wide range of products as you can see here
which range from like human drugs and biological
products animal drugs medical devices tobacco
products food cosmetics and radiation emitting
electronic products and obviously the entire the
camera activity is so vast that it's not
run out of one Center there are several
centers within the FDA which are responsible
for regulating these various aspects of the
agency and these are mentioned on the left
and the right of the screen and yeah we also
have extra additional centers like
the oncology center of excellence
so when you look at cdrh which is one of the
centers as I mentioned it's Center for devices and
radiological health and this is a Center focus on
medical devices and um it goes without saying that
patients are at the heart of what we do and our
centers of vision as articulated by Dr Jeff shurin
and is that we want to ensure that U.S patients
have access to high quality safe and effective
medical devices or public health importance and
first in the world so we shouldn't be lagging
and having these devices come to the use of
the US public in patients as soon as possible
um I wanted to switch uh topics a little bit
going from looking at an agency perspective
to start looking at what do you mean what do
we mean by digital Health technology because
obviously uh when you come from an academic
setting um you have a pretty broad spectrum
of things and so when we think about digital
Health Technologies we see how we see these
things as convergence of computing power
connectivity uh sensors and software that
are used in healthcare and are applicable over
the spectrum of healthcare as you can see from
on the top where I can see from Healthy Living
all the way out to like managing disease or
treatment and having how patients are utilizing
these Technologies in their treatment and Care
Um this can also be either be
used as medical products or be
used to study a medical product or be either
be incorporated into a medical product like a
combination product or can be used as a companion
or adjunct to a medical product including
Diagnostics and Therapeutics so taking a little
bit further on this axis it's like when you look
at the solutions that are coming out in digital
health and Landscape is pretty Broad and if you
look at it you're not only thinking about moving
the healthcare from the clinic to the patient but
you're also trying to understand how behavior and
Physiology is being impacted or looked at in the
real world versus looked at in control clinical
trials right and so digital Health gives us a lot
of power in understanding some of these aspects
which they had difficulty doing before and if you
look at the type of solutions that you're seeing
come out into the marketplace arranged quite a
bit from like wearables where you look at like
sleep apnea monitors or neurological models and
like Telecare which is like activity monitoring
which has been pretty useful for like pandemic
uh conditions as you know and also thinking
of things like health and wellness Solutions
where people uh companies are coming out with
approaches for improving different functions and
trying to make sure that these devices can help
the US patient population as much as possible and
the diversity also gives us an interesting
challenge because basically while you're
trying to achieve the situation
of U.S patients getting access to
um medical devices Public Health importance first
in the world you also want to make sure that they
are high quality and they are safe and effective
so balancing that those two sort of competing
interests is always important to be careful
that we don't miss that Target in that sense
so as you notice the landscape is pretty Broad and
it's evolving very rapidly and so in order to make
sure that the agency was on top of things here
we launched in 2020 the digital Health Center of
Excellence or DH soe and this was basically driven
by our ongoing commitment to advancing access to
uh digital Health technology collaboratively
the goal our goal in the center is to empowered
stakeholders to Advance Health Care by fostering
responsible and high quality digital Health
Innovation and we seek to find ways to tailor
our regulatory approaches um that is fit for
purpose for these Imaging Technologies including
like artificial intelligence and machine learning
which has obviously a huge potential to a personal
impact Public Health in we believe that this is a
shared goal for all stakeholders involved in this
space and we are a partner and contributor in the
overall ecosystem and we want for Australia
responsible Innovation to make sure that
our standards of safety and effect in us are met
from our perspective the digital Health Center of
Excellence has three components in this addressing
this goal um one is that you want to connect the
work that's being done both inside the FDA and
outside the FDA to other parts of the ecosystem
and secondly we want to bring that knowledge
together creating a network that people can
stand upon so that there's less duplication and
we can drive Synergy and the overall emphasis of
all this is to make sure that we can innovate and
that the Innovation not just like new technology
coming to the U.S population but also make
sure that this technology is safe and effective
these are some of the areas of focus as you can
see that it's a pretty broad sort of areas and
it's a sort of living document incense
that obviously new technologies coming
on online as every day and so we had to be on
top of these things and some of these are also
cross-cutting to the Technologies already out
there like real world evidence is a area of
active interest across the entire Center and the
agency and also this is not quite an exhaustive
list obviously but we are looking at a lot
of new and exciting areas of authorization
and looking at it from a pre-marketer and
post Market space like for example virtual
reality and augmented reality and also looking
at AIML and ranging from Advanced manufacturing
approaches also to Patient generated
Health Data or pght as we talk about
so while we before we go down further into this
very uh focused area of interest from a digital
Health perspective I think it's important to make
sure that we are all on the same page on some of
the basic concepts that how the agency looks
at things um versus how we may consider these
words or concepts outside the agency or outside
the scope of a pre-market authorization space
so the first thing is we have to be careful
when you talk about a thing called a device or
a product so when the agency talks about a device
we are basically saying that a definition that
comes to us from the federal drug and cosmetic act
section 201h and that's listed here in detail and
basically the I'm not going to read the whole
definition and you can read it obviously but
there's some key aspects to this definition right
first of all at the top you're having these kind
of um content about what this thing is right like
it could be an instrument apparatus Implement and
so on and so forth but the other two aspects
the key aspects here are the two bullets here
the first one is like what is the intended use
of this particular thing which is going to be
considered as the device well if it is used in
diagnosing a disease or curing mitigating treating
or preventing of disease then it's a device right
and so that's key when you come with the product
to the FDA what are you doing with that product
what is the intended use of that product so that
is one of the key driving forces how we look at
a device how we look at a product whether it's
considered a device for us or not and the second
thing we look at is like okay what is it doing
um like is it intended to affect the structure
or any function of the body and we're also
delineating a device from a drug or a biologic
where we say that it does not achieve its
primarily intended purpose through chemical action
right so a device is not a drug so so we're going
to be careful about how we Define these things
and so it also helps you understand which part
of the agency your particular product might end
up in based upon how you how the intended use
of your device or product is set up and so you
want to be careful when you're thinking about
your product when you're building a product where
you start from an academic Circle to going out to
a startup or to a company and saying okay this
is what I want to do think about this definition
clearly and make sure that what you're doing with
what are you intending to use this particular
thing that you're building where does it fit
in the spectrum of things that can be regulated
um when you talk about devices uh as I said before
it's all dependent upon how you what the intended
use of the devices and also how we describe
or the device is actually doing and what its
technological characteristics are and then based
upon those two criteria the level of regulatory
control from the agency that is going to be given
for that particular product will be inside it and
we typically have three different classes class
one class two and class three and the as you go
up in risk of the device you go to a higher class
and the other thing we have to mention here is
that um basically like we use something called
Product codes or Pro codes which is allowing us to
um group similar devices together and make
sure that we can sort of build a family of
devices where they are doing the same intended
use and so you can if you look at a product
code you can tell what are the devices that
have been cleared under that product code
so um I I believe that this is going to be a
lot of new Concepts coming to you because I
used to be the United and when I moved to
NIH to FDA the language changes of how we
speak about scientific things if I may say that
so here just it may be a little bit confusing
as a lot of new definitions come here just be
patient and you can go back and listen to the
talk and get more feeling understanding
of what actually these concepts mean
so um this slide reiterates some of the points
I mentioned in the previous slide and the key
thing to note here as I said like classes one
two and three and the risk level is increasing
at the higher class but the main thing here is
what are the controls right we have something
called regulatory controls that are applicable
to a product area and these are allowing us to
provide consistent requirements so make sure
that we are predictable safe and effective
medical devices and we have appropriate level
of regulatory oversight on these devices and
so these controls are generally broad but maybe
specific and at the bottom I've listed the general
controls which are applicable even to the lowest
class devices which is basically like you have to
provide labeling for your device then you have
to you have to do medical device reporting for
example if there are device related injuries or
that's you have to report that to the agency then
you have to register your establishment with the
agency and then here they have a device listing
and like you could have like a global device IDs
so approach and then your Quality Systems that you
would have in place make sure that the device is
safe and effective and finally obviously you have
to make sure that you can track more adulteration
and misplanting Concepts and these are the type of
uh submission types that we get to see um Within
These different classes and this basically for a
moderate risk it typically will CFI 10K more than
any other type of submission you will see some
denova submissions too but most of the time it'll
be a 510k or exempt submission then when you go to
the highest risk device you'll pretty much end up
with something called a pre-market approval or PMA
device which is how which will have the highest
amount of regulatory control on those devices
when you look at the class 2 devices besides
the general control we also have something
called special controls and basically what we
see here on the left is these are very they're
specific only to class two devices not for class
1 devices and they're not typically common but
basically applicable for well-established
device types and when you're looking for uh
example of where is a special control applied
then you can look at the when you look at the
code Federal Regulation and you look at the B
section of that particular product it'll tell
you like okay what is the classification what are
the special controls that are applicable to this
particular device and if you look at the I given
some examples this is not an exhaustive list but
these are some of the examples special controls
that are placed on these devices because they are
a little bit higher risk than like a class one
device but they're obviously not as high as as a
class 3 device so you can have requirements when
it's coming in with your pre-market submission
like you need to provide design or characteristics
or specifications then you need to provide testing
you may need special labeling and there are
some guidance documents here to go through
to make sure that your device um satisfies the
special controls or be before it can be allowed
to be authorized to be going out into Market
in the US so here um this is a very simplistic
and brief outline of the steps for bringing a
new product to Market in the US uh through the
FDA and I think the most important part in this
particular slide is the link at the bottom because
um I think cdrh learn would be a very valuable
asset for if if you're bringing a device to Market
in the US because it walks you through uh in
fairly simple approach and logic that how you can
explain all the process aspects for bringing your
device to the market in the US and what are the
various aspects of how we do research How We Do
how you get your data together how you make sure
that your Quality Control process is in place how
you make sure you verify and validate your devices
operation and so some of those things will be more
easily explained in that site um and and this is
this slide doesn't do justice too the expansive
aspect of this thing and but very briefly going
over the slide babe what do you start out this
is pretty much sequentially what you want to
do is lucky first of all you want to establish
your product make sure that it's description and
the intended to use the indications were used the
duration of views like how long should we use in
the Target population like for example uh it could
be age range which you wanted water age range is
it applicable for what type of populations what
disease is it applicable for those kind of things
you want to get that clear first and then you want
to go to like you want to verify that this product
is actually medical device remember as I said the
federal drug Food Drug and cosmetic act tells us
like what is the device and so does your once you
define your intended use does it fit within that
particular definition or not where does it fit
in that scope and then once you've done that like
you want to find the classification regulatory
pathway is it going to be class 1 Class 2 class
3 and which particular pathway do you want to
go down based upon the risk it'll tell you once
you have figured out that these are the things
I have to do then you then go ahead and build
your evidence for your scientific evidence make
sure that you can come in with the free market
submission but I would strongly encourage any
or any of you who's interested in bringing a
device to Market is work with the FDA as early
as possible because the earlier you get those
involved in your process development of even from
like once you established that this is what you
want to do you can come in and talk to us and say
okay this is my intended use where do I fit in
your scope of controls and it might be something
as simple as saying okay your device we don't or
you're a product we don't regulate in which case
you might have a different pathway versus we say
Okay a high risk products because you're doing X Y
and Z and so having that conversation right at the
bat I think it's going to be very valuable rather
than waiting till you are up at step five and then
coming and talking to us and then realizing you
had to go back and redo a lot of things because
you totally misunderpreted what regulatory
systems are so talk to our review divisions as
much as possible and you can all I'll put out
I'll provide an email address reach out to us
and we can connect you with the review divisions
which are appropriate for your particular product
but please do work with us as early as
possible rather than waiting till the end
um but when you talk about devices then
question becomes how does that apply in
the scope of digital health and it gets very
interesting when you talk about devices in the
digital Health Spectrum so we start out on this
initial definition right which is saying the
section 201h of the food drug and cosmetic act
has a definition for device an Indian product
that's not within that spectrum is going to
be something that we considered not a device
so okay that's clean and easy but then the
Nuance that quicksand kicks in is that we have
the 21st stage cures act that came in and said
that okay when you're thinking about software
functions there are some parts of software
functions that should not be considered as
a device that should be regulated by the FDA and
so once you start thinking about that aspect then
you realize that there are a lot of software
Solutions the software functions that you can
develop which don't necessarily have to come
to the FDA and you can go straight to Market
and so this is uh the first guidance I think which
uh which is the power listed at the bottom here
which we call the 3060 guidance and basically what
it is doing is it's listing the changes that apply
to existing medical software policies because
of this cures act and as you can see here from
left to right like there are a lot of software
functions that it talks about which it says that
these are sort of functions that do not need to
be regulated by the FDA and so I'll be going to
more detail into these different sort of functions
um as you go forward but think about when you're
building your product like where does it fit
in this spectrum does it fit in these kind of
um sort of buckets or not and then that's where
you go from like how when you talk to the FDA also
and in the previous slide I mentioned the word
function and I want to make sure that when we
talk about function within the agency or within
like pre-market space or in the authorization
space we have a different meaning than like a
mathematical function right so in here we are
talking about a distinct purpose of a product
and so when we talk about a function a device
function basically it's a function that meets the
definition of a device so that's something that
we can potentially regulate and then when you say
device software function we talk about a software
function that meets the device definition so you
want to be careful that when you say function here
we talk about how does this thing function what
does it do and basically when we and as it goes
back to the pointer is the beginning of this
talk which is like the whole thing hinges on
intended use of the product what is the product
doing so the intended use is a function of that
particular product and you can have multiple
intended users and so for example if you just
are having one intended use which is analyzing the
data then it's only one function which is analyzed
data on the other end if it's Integrity you store
transfer and analyze then it has three different
functions right it has a function to store it
has function to transform it is a function that
will analyze the data that's come through it and
do something with that right so you want to be
careful that when you start to build your product
you have to think about what are the functions of
this product and what which basically translates
to what are the intended uses of this product and
then you can go down to Pathways okay this is
a device function or it's not a device function
and so when you talk about not a device function
sort of thing we talk about other functions and
I'll come back to this later but basically it's
a function that does not mean the definition of
a device so it can be an intended use but it might
be an intent to use that doesn't fit under Section
201 edge of the food drug and cosmetic acts
and so or it could be something like it could
be an exempt kind of function so you want to be
careful about the nuances that apply to any of the
functions of a device and so when we're looking at
which functions are being reviewed by the FDA then
it's it'll be called device function review and
so on and so forth so obviously I'm not suggesting
that you memorize all this and you shouldn't
but it's a slide that I put up we can go back
and look at it and these are definitions that are
available on the FDA website and you can look at
them and understand the nuances of how things
are looked at when they come into the agency
the other thing I was also going to mention is
when you think about the intended years which
I mean uh sort of mentioning all along is like
um we had an amendment um to this in intended
use through the 24-hour CFR code of federal
court Federal Regulation 801 where basically
like there was some aspect related to okay how
do you define intended use right how do you know
what the products intended to use is and so
here we provided more clarity and Direction
regarding what type of evidence can be used to
determine its intended use and so we can use any
relevant source of evidence which can include
direct evidence you might have supplied or
um to us when you submitted your application or
like interact with circumstantial evidence such as
how you're selling the product in the marketplace
and quotes that recognized that self-serving
labels cannot be used or cannot be allowed
to mask the vendors true intent as indicated
by the overall circumstances so the intended
use can be determined using these different
um approaches to truly understanding whether
person or the spawn the device manufacturer or
product manufacturers how is how are they trying
to sell this device so what is it being sold for
so going back to the regulatory
classification question when you
talk about digital Health Products um where
does a particular digital Health product sit
is dependent upon the risk categorization
of that device and the intended use of the
device so you can either be a not a device
we are looking at remember a device is not
a product device is something the ftnc act or
we can intend to use exercise something called
enforcement discretion and I'll come to that
in the future next subsequent slide or it'll
be under the regulatory oversight of the Ft in
which case it's a different pathway it goes down
so when you look at software functions right and
um basically like if it's a software function
the we want to look at how it's regulated and you
can see at the bottom there's an error which goes
increasing risk and basically as I said in the
previous slide as a risk of a device increases
the risk of the intendities of the device
increases then the more oversight comes into
play from the fda's perspective and so if you're
on the left hand side of the risk cab flow then
you are basically looking at functions that
are intended for like a log record so this is
an example right so in which case we're saying
that you can either log record track a wallet
or make decisions or behavioral suggestions
but there's no reference to a disease or a
condition in this in this particular example on
the other hand we start adding more information
like we're trying to help smokers quit or
you want to help patients recovering from
addiction or you're developing apps or pregnant
women then these are apps or you may the risk
level is higher and then the agency has an
intent to exercise enforcement discretion
depending on the where the risk sits on that
particular profile for those particular devices
and finally then if you're looking at a product
where you're building a sort of function that uses
sensors or leads to track measure and display
like electrical signal like ECG then those
are higher risk products and so we definitely
have a regulatory oversight on those products
foreign so in order to help industry and
consumers get clarity on the regulatory
aspects related to software um cdrh has been
has released a number of guidance documents
over the last few years as I've shown here uh
some of these are in draft state which means
that there's not considered final guidances
and they are currently they're accepting
public comment or we are evaluating uh comments
that have been provided by the public before
after the commenting period is closed and the
final guidance will be published sometime soon
um but definitely these are documents that
are can be sometimes difficult to read and
understand but can be once I mean they're
very valuable in helping you understand how
the agency is interpreting uh authorizations
or Congressional authorizations rewarded to it
I think the key uh tool that you may want to
start out with is something called the digital
Health policy Navigator this is something that the
digital Health Center of Excellence recently made
available it's on our fta's website and this is
mainly to help product developers understand how
their software function fits within the regulatory
framework of the agency it's an interactive
workflow and you basically uh answer different
questions which are shown here like different
steps and based upon how we answer these questions
it's a rule-based system where it basically takes
you down different Pathways and it tells you like
okay based upon how we answered a particular set
of questions um you will either be like will
not be a medical device or it could be some a
device or a product where enforcement discretion
applies or a device where you have to come in
and talk to us and have regulatory oversight on
that and so and it's a nice starting point it's
um but it's not the be all an end also just
because it tells you one thing it doesn't
necessarily mean you shouldn't and talk to us
but I think it's a good starting point to tell
you where you are in that spectrum of which
guidance is applied to your particular device
so I want to do a deeper dive into some of the
aspects related to software functions that we
talked about and so um I'm going to start with
more of the functions that we don't have the FDA
doesn't have kind of considered as devices and so
this is coming from the section 5201a of the fdnc
act and basically any software function that you
build which is for administrative administrative
support of a healthcare facility those types
of functions are historically not considered to
be devices by the agency and so I've provided
some examples here where basically if you are
uh tracking Financial records claims of
billing information or you're looking
at building scheduling for your medical staff or
if you're building a software for like analyzing
historical claims data for cost effect in us or
looking at health benefit eligibility those are
the functions that the FDA doesn't get in um
look at as devices it's not to say that any
other regulatory agency within the federal
government may or may not have it uh opinion
on how these functions are deployed but from the
FDA perspective this is not something we look at
um then the second one I think it's a interesting
one for digital health because they will see a lot
of products out there that make a large number of
General awake claims about health so uh when we
talk about General Wellness we we are basically
considering two different types of products so
one is that either the intended for only General
Wellness use as defined in the guidance of General
Wellness or and they present at lower risk to the
safety of these in other persons and basically
what we're saying here is that we do not intend
to examine low risk General Wellness products
and basically the thing becomes like how how
are you defining these kind of risk low risk
and General Wellness and so one of the ways if
you look at the guidance the two categories that
we talk about winter about low risk and uh but if
you make if your product is making claims about
sustaining or offering General Improvement uh to
functions associated with the general cdfl then
do not make any reference to disease or condition
then that's one category of General Wellness on
the other hand if you're talking about making
reference to disease or condition you're only
um making intelligence claims of sustaining
or offering General Improvement functions
associated with the general state of health and
so basically we are talking about relationship
between healthy lifestyle choices and
sustaining a general state of health so
think about these aspects when you are trying to
think whether you're in the devices your products
intended to use is a general awareness or
not and so when you are in that space I
would recommend again as I said before come and
talk to us the next one I want to talk about is
electronic health records and this is an
interesting area of focus basically that
um under the section 5201 C of the fdmc ACT some
software functions that are intended to serve as
electronic patient records are not considered
as devices and so these are three different
conditions that apply they have to all we have to
be met and the first two I think the third one is
the most interesting one and basically the first
one basically says we're creating it for people
like for healthcare professionals or individuals
working under Healthcare professionals supervision
are the ones looking at creating and storing or
reviewing these kind of Records they also have
to be part of like no NC Office of the national
coordinator for Health Information Technology
based upon the Public Health Service Act 3001 CF
and so if it's under that program and the third
thing which is important is to know that these
should not be intended for interpretation analysis
no patient records including like medical image
data but the purpose of diagnosis cure mitigation
prevention on treating of disease or condition
and if you if you remember this the last part of
the language actually comes if from the food
food drug and cosmetic act right we'll talk
about the intendities of this particular function
and where does it fit in so if you're using that
particular function for these kind
of activities then yes that would
be a device because of the it's doing diagnosis
cure and all that other potential possibilities
the other thing to mention about the EHR is that
basically at this time there's some overlap with
um I think I mentioned the second criteria that
there's overlap the onc uh which is part of the
statutory definition of this particular uh process
and so even after you established that a product
is an EHR you have to be careful the fact is that
when you're talking about product functions that
just because you have an EHR function does
not mean that other functions of your device
are not or every product are not a device right
so you want to be careful about you might have
one function which is the HR but there might be
another function which might be doing something
which is which can be considered as the device
for the FDA so you want to consider all these
functions separately and also a value you want
to evaluate that anything either you add new
functionality to your product see how that impacts
within that fdnc act and again going back to the
3060 act 3060 guidance you want to look at how
the different criteria are describing electronic
health records for healthcare professionals and
we also said that in the second bullet we're
talking about like how if it enables patients
individuals to non-healthcare Providers to
create store or transfer health records They are
considered personal health records so these are
not meant for as I said before because they're
not meant for intended use of diagnosis key or
mitigation so on so forth they would also not be
considered devices under the ftnc ACT section 201h
um going on to the next guidance um this one is uh
interesting one because it's talking about medical
device it's a pretty long name for the guidance
which is basically talking about medical device
Data Systems medical image storage devices and
medical image Communications devices and we I
have a short economy for that it's called mdds
and basically these are hardware and software
Hardware or software products that are mainly
intended to transfer store convert formats and
display medical device data the key here is
that the mtds cannot or does not modify the
data or modify the display of the data and does
not control the functional parameters so like
for example if you think about a hardware device a
router would be considered Hardware device it just
transfers data from one point to point point A to
point B and it doesn't modify the data or modify
the display of the data and does not control the
functional parameters of any other medical device
so it depends on how you look at it and it's very
valuable to think about your device whether it's
an mdds or non-mtds and so when you think about um
mtds system we have software functions and we have
Hardware functions and so each of these can be
considered differently and if it's it's a software
function that just transfers towards a converts
format and doesn't uh do all the modifications
that are controlled then it's not a device and
it won't be subject to regulate requirements
similarly when you think about Hardware
functions that again do the same kind of
activity or actions then those are
considered as device mdds and for
certain device entities we do not
intend to enforce the requirements
the next interesting part as you transition
from like General Wellness from tmtds to
clinical decision support systems um this is
a interesting area because there's a lot of
action we're seeing from artificial intelligence
so machine learning related to clinical dishes
and support systems and so CDs is basically a
tool that allows Healthcare professionals and
patients to get more information and to filter
that and have it presented to them at appropriate
time to ensure that health and Healthcare is
delivered correctly um so the key is obviously
you want to make sure that these are all safe
and effective and there are a lot of different
aspects of CDs as you can see here like you can
range from like clinical guidances guidelines
to developing diagnostic support or having
contextually relevant reference information so uh
this field is pretty big and Broad and we have
um um the cures act has talked about like the
5201e that the fdnc ACT has also provided some
information like as to how do we decide whether
the particular CDs is uh something that should
be considered as a device or can be excluded
from the device function and so there are four
statutory criteria that have been defined in
this particular section of the ACT which are
allowing us to determine whether particular
function becomes a device or not device and so
when we talk about non-device we're talking about
basically those functions that do not mean the
definition of device right that we talked about
before and the other thing is like when you talk
about functions which are excluded from device
definition we have to be clear that these are
independent of the platform that they're being
run on so it could be running on as Android or
iOS it doesn't matter it does you know these
functions are excluded from device definition
independent of that so these are the four criteria
from the cures act right and so the key here
is that all four conditions have to be met or
um there so if you look at it uh there it starts
you start from the first one you go down the rank
that way and basically the first two are basic
input kind of uh aspects basically you're saying
that is it intended to acquire process analysts
a medical image or the second one is intended
for displaying something and then the last term I
mean look came from the output perspect like is it
providing an intended to provide recommendation
and for finally is it like intended for enabling
uh Healthcare professional independently
review the basis of such recommendations
so any CDs software that you develop it has
to meet all four conditions to be excluded
from the device definition so it can be a little
hard to make sure that you hit all four of them
um this cartoon like sketch or graphic outline
which is available online fda's website
um it's sort of like a cheat sheet of how this
process works and so the top row is basically
saying that if it meets all these four criteria
that are shown here then that particular one would
be considered as a non-device CDS but if it fails
any of them then you are no longer you are pretty
much a device and we will be regulating
you and so for example if you look at uh
a device example if you're looking at
in vitro Diagnostics or you can MRI and
next-gen sequencing those kind of functions are
you're failing this particular step one right
and then you go to like step two for already
looking at like ECG you are looking at Medical
images and then this question becomes okay how
are you looking at those confirmation and then
the other examples here looking at like
Risk score for disease or conditions and
probability of a disease or a condition that you
might have and then final time critical outputs
are something that we always are concerned about
and finally like here we look at if you if your
AI for example if a algorithm is not providing
the basis of the recommendation that it provides
you as to why a vertical action is Justified
to be taken and if if the clinician cannot
understand why that's being done then that's
something that people want to see as a device
um going further down we're talking about
um policy for device software functions the Mobile
Medical applications or as you call it the tsf MMA
guidance and this is an interesting guidance
because it's a it's a fairly broad guidance
and it's very useful reading to understand what
kind of aspects of digital Health come under the
different Umbrellas of whether it's a device or
it comes under reinforcement discretion or whether
it's regulated by the FDA and so I think it's a
very useful starting point when you start to look
at digital Health Products like which guidance
you want to start with I think I would recommend
this particular guidance it's all our guidance is
obviously well written but this I think feels like
a very nicely collected Gardens and it's sort
of like a first go-to guidance when we have any
example or a question come into us about a digital
Health inquiry and then we say okay how did we
interpret it in this particular guide and so I
think um if you're starting out in the field it's
a good guide to start out with and some of the
other aspects related to this particular guidance
is beside the fact that it defines some of these
functions it also talks about like we do not
regulate the sale or you generally use of consumer
use or smartphones or tablets and so this was one
of the things I think comes easy out output
from this guidance but I think as I mentioned
before the main things that are relevant here is
the fact that we're talking about where are the
regulatory oversights that have been established
through this guidance we're talking about
um it walk um basically we're talking about which
software functions are medical devices are not
medical devices and which are the ones where
we intend to exercise enforcement discretion
and the right hand side talks about what do we
mean by enforcement discretion right basically
we're saying that even if it meets the definition
of medical device we do not intend to exercise
enforcement like basically like uh we believe
that these functions are for proposing lower
risk to the public based upon the evidence we have
in the field or from scientific literature and so
um generally we intend to exercise enforcement
discussion for several different types of
examples and um if it's something that's helping
a patient self-manage the disease or condition
without providing specific treatment or treatment
suggestions then we definitely are looking in that
space and so I'll list two here but this is
not exhaustive and if you if you you can go
back to that guidance and look at the different
examples and different scenarios that have been
laid out of how enforcement policies uh
implemented in those conditions I think
um that would be a good guidance look through
the last one I want to talk about is something
called the multiple function guidance and this
is a when you think about a product which has
multiple functions um remember we talk about let
me say functions we talk about internet use and so
um depending on different intended use this
guidance gives you clarity about how we look
at the other functions right and so you look at
the right hand side we talk about what's another
function well it doesn't meet the definition of a
device or if it meets it then there's some kind of
exemption that's applicable or if it's meeting
the difference but some kind of intent the FDA
is expression is not to enforce compliance and so
when you talk about these kind of other functions
as being part of a device itself then how does
the FDA look at those particular functions
and this particular guy this multiple function
guidance walks you through some of those aspects
so just because they're part of a multiple
function device doesn't mean we want to look
at it on the other hand we will look at how this
particular other function impacts the the device
function that we're actually interested in right
so you want to make sure that the device function
that you're reviewing are not in their safety and
infection is not impacted by these other function
that you have sitting on the side so for example
if you have a general purpose Computing platform
we don't regulate that but we are interested
to know how does that General function general
purpose Computing platform that you're using for
your app which is sitting on top of that how does
that interaction work and how are you ensuring
that your app is safe and effective when there are
issues or aspects related to the general purpose
Computing platform so we would ask for that kind
of connection to be established and so similarly
for the hardware that if you are looking at uh
integrastic balloon which is subject to a PMA
or pre-market approval and you have an endoscope
accessory that is 510k exempt for example in a
desktop guide where we may still want to see how
this guide were impact the safety infection of the
balloon so in that sense you have to be careful
that when you look at devices multiple functions
how do the other functions interact with your
function that you're actually coming
to the agency with for authorization
so um basically if you look through the gardens
it'll talk you through like you want to look at
do a risk assessment right and so when you do a
risk assessment you want to see what the other
function impacts as far as the device function
that review if there's a positive impact like
it improves safety and Effectiveness right for
example uh increase gpus or higher neural net or
something like that then you want it obviously
improves processing speed but it has something
that we want to look at and also you want to see
if there's an adverse effect right if it's for
example you added some kind of lower capacity Ram
or something like that in which case obviously a
computation time slows down and so we would like
to know what kind of or if you added a software
Library which has slower computation now it was
not updated for a while then in which case those
functions can impact adversely so you want to know
how does that particular function even though it's
not necessarily something we would have looked
at but question becomes how does it impact the
safety and effectiveness of the device function
that we are looking at and then so once you've
considered all those aspects of risk assessment
then you need to include that in a pre-market
submission that tells us how these other functions
impact um this the device function that review and
you you mainly do that when you either positively
impacting and you're going to show that uh for the
function the review and or if it's negatively
impacting the device function in the review
so I know this is in a whirlwind
tour of digital Health at cdrs and
um Jack has my slide and this information and as I
said cdrs learn is a great site to go to to learn
more about how we look at different devices
and how we regulate them I want to conclude
by just summarizing some of the aspects I had
on during this talk which is basically saying
like when you talk about software function it's a
device if it's intended for use in the diagnosis
cure mitigation treatment or prevention of a
disease or condition and so what we the way
we the vocabulary we use if we call them device
software functions so remember the word device
has its own meaning and then we take what software
functions that are meeting this device definition
so that's how we Define software functions and
then when you look at the 21st century cures act
um there's some software functions that are
excluded from definition of a device so and
we have as I walked you through several of
our guidances these can help you understand
okay whether your particular product is coming
under that or not right and so they'll help you
understand like whether you um you need to walk
through all the different aspects or not but I
think at this end of the day having good quality
control systems in your processes as you build
your product is going to be always valuable even
if it's a device not authorized not coming under
FDA uh or purview I think for success of your
product and your company I think it's valuable
for you to build good quality control systems
within your product development processes so
that's something I would encourage and then when
you look at regulatory oversight we're looking at
primarily sort of functions that are medical
devices and we're looking at risk categorization
if it's functionality failure would impact the
safety of the patient then it's something we're
really interested and want to oversee uh like
from a regulatory perspective and as I mentioned
uh towards the last few slides that we recognize
that there are function products that have more
than one function or more than one intended use
and so the question becomes like you want to
make sure that when your other functions how about
those other functions impacting the function that
you're looking at from a regulatory perspective
and you want to make sure that we look at both
positive and negative aspects of those other
functions and the last thing I want to point out
is like there are several ways you can reach out
to us we have the digital Health inbox which is
as shown here digital Health at fda.sha should go
where a number of guidance documents that you have
released and we also have regulatory tools such as
the digital helpers Navigator and also cdrs learn
is another valuable tool which you can use to get
to understand how you bring your product to Market
in the U.S so this is the last slide and basically
if you have any questions you can either reach out
to digital Health at fda.hs.gov or you can email
me also directly if you need to thank you vinay
thank you so much this um stuff you talked about
here I think will be of a lot of interest to many
folks who are parts of our biomedical data sense
Innovation lab and generally speaking a lot of at
least the work that we're familiar with through
our interactions with the community from where
we sit here at UVA have been in the space of
developing computational algorithms that are
linked to some sort of biometric device and so
what you're talking about here where there's the
device itself and there's the software there's
the interaction between the two I think this is
exactly the kind of information that people who
have these if they're looking at cardiac function
or they've got their uh you know basically looking
at the eye for example or they're you know making
some other metric like with a wearable device that
and they want to Market it that this is the kind
of information they need definitely and I think
um the one thing I mentioned at the beginning and
I will keep happening awaited because we have
discussions with within the agency also like
um any developer of a software should come and
talk to us as early as possible and uh we are
friendly we we are nice to talk to us so uh please
do reach out early don't wait till the last minute
and then you I mean it's a lot of investment
as I mean when you build startups it's a lot
of upfront Investments you want to make sure
that at a minimum you're on the right path for
this particular product I think that's very very
good advice one of the things that um I wanted to
ask about is and we were sort of talking a little
bit about this before we got started today but you
brought it up several times and you really kind
of iterated on it um about how much terms matter
um and the definitions of these words that perhaps
those of us who don't know any better would use
interchangeably but you point out um rightly
so that you know that there is a difference
between in a device and a product and you gave
several other uh several resources to uh for
people to look at to avoid confusion are there
any common mistakes that people make in mixing
up terms that could you know they might use in
one context but to the FDA mean something else
um how to come back and look at because
I'm pretty sure there are now I've been so
immersed in the FDA approach of thinking about
things like sometimes it's hard like I think I
mentioned before the call like the word signal has
a different meaning within FTA connotations and
um I think also like words like monitoring or
I mean so post Market is an interesting space
where we look at how devices perform in the real
world and so some of those aspects related to how
devices are monitored or tracked can be meaning
different things of different agencies and so I
think that's one aspect I think device and product
is the most obvious one I think because we have
a clear I mean we food Dragon cosmetic is act is
clearly defined for us what that means and those
words have specific meanings and I think the
other place where we are had aspects that is
in AIML because especially when you talk about
bias trying to understand different types of
bias like statistical bias versus systemic bias
and understanding explainability of a algorithm
those are some of the nuances that are different
from different uh perspective not just within the
agencies but also even in the academic Community
as to understanding what those particular words
mean and I think one thing I was going to mention
is that we have something called the imtrf which
is international medical device Regulators forum
and we have started to build glossary of words
and so that we also understand when we're saying
a particular verb that we're talking about the
same thing and sometimes it can get lost that we
may be talking about the same word but me talking
about totally different concepts and then takes a
while to get back to the same space yeah I think
that's probably super important just to have
a thesaurus of you know what those terms are
um one of the things that occurred to me as
you were mentioning about evidence and that
word and what that means is is the evidence
that one needs to provide in their application
is it in narrative form only or is like is
there an expectation of a live demonstration
in front of an FDA representative that
your device does what it says it does
so um it's mostly been the farmer but we also had
situations where it has helped us understand more
about what a device does by having a demonstration
obviously I mean it's not a requirement so it's up
to the so when we so when we use the word sponsor
a company coming in to submit to us is called a
sponsor right they're sponsoring the product to
come in for review and so when a sponsor comes in
uh and they show us a video or they show us their
uh product it makes it a lot easier to connect the
dots between what you're seeing on paper versus
what you're actually seeing in uh demonstration
and so we have several examples of when we look at
a submission and say are you doing X Y and Z and
then we have a conversation with the sponsor
and they show us a demonstration of what the
product does and we realize how it does X but it
doesn't do y and its intended uses not this but
it's the other thing and so it's it's been always
helpful to us to have a demonstration or a video
and obviously uh with the pandemic and all it's
been hard to have a Hands-On demo but you can do
video presentation about your product but part
of the thing is also we don't want to put on new
um burden on the sponsors saying that if somebody
cannot do a video it doesn't mean they should be
impaired from having their device looked at like
the right circumstances so it's not a requirement
and but it definitely helps to understand where
you're coming from as a device manufacturer that's
great and a lot of people I imagine in in this day
and age we've sort of gotten used to it is with
wearable devices and things that you can wear on
your wrist or on your head or on your finger for
that matter are internet enabled and they have
you know Bluetooth technology attached to them
that connect to your cell phone or they connect
to the internet in some shape or form and I'm
curious if the FDA works with other agencies for
where necessary for example like the Fed Federal
Communications Commission when you're dealing
with things that involve say you know Wireless
or wired communication Technologies does that make
sense yeah yeah so we do work at a FCC and FTC and
obviously we do work with onc and the CMS so we
we do all work with different agencies but if it's
just one particular product that we're looking
at the review of that product is typically done
in-house only we don't necessarily go outside we
um also have something called a network of experts
for even for digital Health we call it nodex which
is network of digital Health experts and so we use
these network of experts to help and understand
if you have questions about some scientific aspect
of things that so we reach out to them and have
these broad not product specific but like fairly
broad questions about like okay in this particular
field these are if these are the kind of questions
we have how would we answer that and so that's
one way we do it and we do work with the FCC and
FTC like Federal Trade community and to understand
like what are the kind of broad ranging aspects or
different technologies that we have to think about
especially like within the low energy Bluetooth
and trying to understand the like security
implications so we have a separate division within
um cdrs looking at cyber security aspect of
different devices and which is a very strongly I
mean it's a very uh top a strong topic of interest
for the agency because of the various aspects of
how safety and effectiveness of devices can be
impaired by hacks and Legacy devices being sort
of unprotected so we had a lot of interest in that
space and yeah we do talk to other agencies on
that front you sort of predicted my next question
which was uh what are one of the things that or
any of the things because I think you touched on
it but you you didn't really go into the details
because you were talking about other things but
about subject and patient privacy certainly with
you know you're developing a device perhaps it's
you know linked to you in some way and yet it's
you know sending information over the internet are
there any things that you look at specifically to
help make sure that uh data that's transmitted
is private store you know the Phi is removed
I don't know what some of the other things might
be but uh I'm curious about how you address those
so I think it depends uh so for almost all
our product questions the answer is always
it depends right and so if the company needs
that PS information to make diagnosis like if
it's a class 3 product or a product where there's
a patient specific recommendation being made then
obviously they want to have that connectivity
to the patient so from that perspective the
company has to be responsible and has to show in
the documentation to submit to us how are they
protecting the patient information how are they
making sure that um that confidentially is ensured
we as an agency don't see that information because
that's obviously not part of the submission that
comes to us but it's basically like make
sure that the company knows how that has
to protect the information let us be enforcing
these aspects related to how the patients feel
about using the devices and when you talk about
safety and Effectiveness you also think about
like human factors right like when we talk about
AR VR devices you want to understand like how are
the human factors looked at when you're looking at
these devices and again they are the confidential
of information about like surgeons you want to
understand make sure that you're looking at data
um inappropriate way and making sure the data is
uh protected so definitely yeah that's something
we do um strongly uh work with the vendors
make sure that they have it under control
from that angle um that's great well benade
we've reached the end of our time but thank
you so much for sharing this with us this is
really valuable information and I think it's
important because it comes from some place that
you know we don't complete in our history here
in the uh biomedical data science Innovation
lab activities we haven't really heard from the
FDA before and so uh thank you for sharing this
with us because I know for a fact there's a lots
of uh people who are interested in this space
and productize it rather not productizing but
they're basically taking their devices and their
and their other uh research products and marketing
them and having the help of you and Folks at the
FDA would really be valuable for them cool thank
you very very much everyone have a great weekend
and uh we'll see you next week bye now thanks